[Musique]
face à un manque de moyens flagrant est
une urgence sanitaire pour le moins
évidente la solidarité nationale
s'organisent pour tenter d'aider les
soignants à lutter contre le coc vite 19
et ses effets dévastateurs c'est donc
dans cette démarche d'entrée est que le
groupe canal+ via son organisation
canal+ brand solution a choisi
d'organiser une opération spéciale pour
venir en aide financièrement aux
hôpitaux de france entre le 6 et le 12
avril prochain toutes les recettes
générées par l'écran publicitaire
diffusée chaque soir à 20h seront
entièrement reversés à la fondation de
france dans le cadre de son action
commune avec l'institut pasteur
l'ap-hp et de nombreux acteurs engagés
sur le terrain intitulé 20h solidaire
cette opération sera effective sur
toutes les antennes du groupe canal à
savoir canal + c'est news ces stars et
bien sûr c'est vite
alors là ça c'était l'autre buteur du
jour c'était ton coup de coeur aussi
mathieu nous à paris bien sûr que ça je
suis maintenant saint-geniès qui font
évidemment ça formidable de reverser
enfin l'oeil
encore une fois c'est canal+ qui fait un
geste formidable pendant compte pendant
le confinement ils l'ont fait pour
occuper les gens pour éviter la déprime
pour éviter la dépression que les gens
soient seuls se tapent dessus
c'est par une habitude en fait y'a
encore des gens qu russie a critiqué
notamment forte vision et là ce qu'ils
font avec capuche c'est super aussi
voilà le la tranche de plume de 20h qui
reversait je trouve c'est une très très
belle action est hélas doute qu'il
devrait suivre l'affirmé jean louis
nauges et jeudi j'ai seulement j'espère
que tf1 m'a pas une fois de plus on se
tait nous et m6 ont paradé en parlant de
concurrence déloyale qui passe par des
ballons alors alors voilà je suis pas
d'accord avec vous qu'il fasse pareil
chacun fait ce qu'il veut c'est comme
quand on dit chez nous alors qu'il ya
des maps et il a le droit celui ci les
autres joueurs ils n'ont pas envie de
donner son rein droit si chacun fait ce
qu'il veut cité par mti et effrontée ils
font ce qu'ils veulent moi de dire ils
ont qu'à faire pareil je suis pas
d'accord avec vous
d'accord c'est comme le groupe canal qui
fait beaucoup d'initiatives lancement
est alors oui bah oui il va pas se
battre donc on va pas leur lécher le cul
non plus mais je suis désolé les mecs
n'est pas là aussi pour faire les voilà
pour mieux passer la pommade de groupe
parce qu'on est dedans faut arrêter il
ya d'autres bonnes actions aussi dans
notre groupe donc bravo mon savoir faire
mais arrêter là je crois que vous en
remettre là vous en faites un petit peu
trop voilà bien